i'd like to talk about the absolute best
remedy to lower your cholesterol not
that cholesterol is bad but let's say
for example you're doing the ketogenic
diet and your cholesterol goes up and
you're a bit concerned well there's a
couple things you need to know number
one your body makes cholesterol in fact
75 percent of all the cholesterol in
your body is made by your body only 25
comes from
the diet so our body needs cholesterol
also when you burn fat
part of that fat is cholesterol so when
you lose weight the cholesterol has to
come out so you may notice a increase in
your cholesterol for a period of time
now if you're on a low carb diet you
don't need to be concerned some people
that are concerned should do something
called the advanced lipid profile test
that will do a deep dive into the type
of ldl particle size that you have and
there's different types of ldl
i'm going to put a link down below if
you're not familiar with that but that's
a whole different topic but just so you
know
cholesterol in itself is not a good
indicator of
whether you have heart disease or not a
much better test is the cac test or what
is called the coronary artery
calcification test but that's a really
good test to do as a predictor of
mortality but i want to share with you
some really interesting information
about cholesterol
now you have the liver you have the bile
ducts and you have something called the
gallbladder right
so bile that is made by your liver
stored in your gallbladder
is used as a primary way that you remove
cholesterol from it so i'm not sure if
you knew that or not but bile is a
really really important uh fluid in the
body
that is essential in regulating
cholesterol
and
bile is actually even made from
cholesterol bile is like a detergent
that helps you break down fats in
general it helps you extract fat soluble
vitamins
it helps to prevent microbes from
accumulating in your small intestine so
you can prevent a condition called sibo
small intestinal bacterial overgrowth
bile is also essential for extracting
omega-3 fats from your diet in fact all
your fat cyber vitamins cannot be
absorbed unless you have
bile so it's very very important there's
two types of bile okay you got primary
bile which is made by your liver but you
also have something else called
secondary bile salts which is made by
your microbiome the friendly bacteria in
your large intestine and so if there's
any problem with your microbiome okay
that could be the reason why you don't
have enough bile
and that could be the reason why your
cholesterol is even going higher so we
need a very healthy diversified
microbiome to make enough bile to be
able to regulate cholesterol in fact
there's some interesting studies out
there that shows that taking probiotics
significantly lower cholesterol and if
you don't already know this fiber also
reduces cholesterol i wonder why well
because it feeds the microbes that then
make bile salts and i'm not talking
about taking a fiber supplement i am
talking about consuming vegetables or
even better yet a combination of
fermented vegetables that have not only
the prebiotic but the probiotic as in
kimchi or sauerkraut now another common
remedy that's been totally proven to
lower
ldl and increase hdl
is niacin okay that's b3
niacin also by the way increases the
conversion
of cholesterol to bile so niacin is
another interesting piece of the puzzle
that can help lower cholesterol directly
as well as help you have more bile to
then remove the cholesterol if it's in
an excess amount now another interesting
note is that when people have their
gallbladders removed
the
vldl increases okay this is very low
density lipoproteins so in other words
if you remove the gallbladder you might
not have enough primary bile salts to
take away this cholesterol and certain
lipids can start increasing so one of
the best remedies for helping you with
cholesterol
is probiotics and i highly recommend you
get your probiotics from food if
possible sauerkraut is awesome kimchi is
amazing but you can also do a probiotic
supplement as well now let's say for
example you have a genetic problem with
cholesterol or you have a lipid profile
that you're a little concerned about and
you really want to lower this
cholesterol you can also add tutca which
is a certain type of bile salt that you
can buy
that will help you lower your
cholesterol as well as niacin don't get
the niacinamide get the niacin version
of b3 and that will create a nice
cholesterol lowering effect now the next
most important video for you to watch
is the one on ldl there's actually two
different types of ldl and i put that
video up right here check it out